let's get ourselves in trouble with all
of the people who
uh consider zero hedge problematic okay
zacho all right so here we have
zero hedges uh report on
this preprint that emerged
um yeah i'm not sure it even counts as a
pre-print right
oh it's because it's not on a pre-print
server yeah yeah it's so what is this
document and i must tell you
one we can also show the document yeah
you want to show the document i sent you
a pdf
i've got it here hold on so brett you
for people listening
yeah so for people listening what we've
got is a paper here the title of the
paper is unusual features of the sars
cove ii
genome suggesting sophisticated
laboratory modification
rather than natural evolution and
delineation of its probable
synthetic route the lead author
is yan now i must say i don't know yan
she's been in this landscape for
um months now and
the chinese virologist who had been
working and living in hong kong who left
hong kong
um without the authorities in her home
country wanting her to presumably in
april of this year i think
right so i have trepidation about her
work in part because
it is traveling outside of the
realms that might allow you to you know
as you point out not a pre-print
right not on a pre-print server now i'm
not sure why i'm more troubled by
a a paper put out outside of a pre-print
server given that the pre-print servers
have requirements about credentials um
and that
that can be used to bar certain things
but nonetheless i mean the fact is
that the regardless of who's in
premature is on this
uh with regard to the organization uh
that is
that is named here we've got what is it
for
four phds who've written a paper that
is very well researched actually if you
can just put that down
so i can read the screen here um here we
go
um just second paragraph of the
introduction as a coronavirus sars cove
to differ significantly from other
respiratory and or zoonotic viruses
it attacks multiple organs it is capable
of undergoing a long period of
asymptomatic infection
it is highly transmissible and
significantly lethal in high-risk
populations
it is well adapted to humans since the
very start of its emergence
it is highly efficient in binding the
human ace2 receptor
the affinity of which is greater than
that associated with the ace2 of any
other potential host
and it goes on and on and on so a this
fits with a number of things that we
talked about
early in our live streams and that you
talked about with yuri deegan
um in the podcast that you did with him
uh
and you know they've just they also a
big part of their argument here is
that there has been active censorship by
the scientific community and by the
journals
um presumably at least potentially also
therefore by the pre-print servers
themselves
um against publishing anything that
suggests uh a lab origin for the virus
right and you know and we did this for
like 18 episodes running back
in our first 18 or so episodes but um
you know lab origin is not the same
thing as bioweapon we're talking about
um you know to say lab origin does not
specify whether or not you're talking
about
an inadvertent escape um on one end to
an intentional release of an intentional
bioweapon on the other or anything in
between
and you know really most of these
analyses are imagining it's some sort of
like oh my god this is being developed
and it escaped and no one ever meant it
to but really nothing about
how it got out into the world is part of
the analysis
around does it or does not does it not
have a lab origin
i guess the other thing is as people
who've been watching for a long time
will understand
that lab origin doesn't mean created
from scratch in the lab
it means uh you know borrowed um
from other viruses and um
made into a chimera slash engineered
primarily from parts that's one of the
things it means composited
from natural sources but the other thing
that it means which has very ominous
implications here
is what's called serial passage
experiments basically
use selection in the lab artificial
selection
to imbue viruses with capacities that
they wouldn't otherwise have and so
again don't know what to make of this
paper though it looks to be very well
researched but the paper is putting
together some of the things that we did
talk about early on about
how much of the frightening part of this
virus
you know it's diversity of organs that
it attacks
right its ability to transmit between
human beings how many of these features
are actually the result
of a guided evolutionary process in a
lab
coupled with a compositing which could
be
of totally honorable origin in other
words people who wish to study a virus
that was dangerous to humans may have
created a virus that was unusually
dangerous to humans
and then it got out through an accident
so that's the most likely scenario as
far as i'm concerned
and um we are now beginning to see
analyses that
strongly reflect this so at a different
level
zack i would ask you to put up the uh
the alina
chan article from boston from the
okay here it is um
right so here what we have is
a profile of somebody i've been
following online
since boy i don't know
march something like that uh
alina chan who is a
young researcher a problem solver
who became suspicious of the
origin story of sars cove ii on the
basis of many things primary among them
is something else you will have heard us
discuss here many times
which is the fact that this virus hit
the ground
running and was already extremely well
adapted to infect human beings rather
than well that's in that list that i
read from here in this
in this paper right and so in any case
um
this article is written for lay audience
it's very accessible i highly recommend
it
and it does a number of things one it
tells
told me a lot of things i didn't know
about dr chan um
one of them that i'm particularly
intrigued by
uh is that her story as a scientist
is not a typical one of her having been
a brilliant student and
this and that she uh somebody who didn't
love school
always bridled against its uh its
constraints
and um has in spite of those things
emerged as
a um a brilliant virologist who
has spotted all the things that were
wrong about the story of sars cove ii
and investigated them and has
established many of these
claims on a very rigorous basis
falsified for example the claim about
pangolins
and the source of the spike protein so
anyway i would just recommend this
article to people we will post a link to
it
um but uh i i don't know maybe uh maybe
dr chan will come on the dark horse
podcast at some point because she seems
like a true dark horse